Buongiorno, un po' di tempo fa mi sono
pesato e la mia bilancia ha chiesto
veramente, piangendo, di salire uno alla
volta e ho capito quindi che la
situazione era abbastanza tragica. Così ho
postato su Instagram un sondaggio nel
quale chiedevo se provare la dieta
crudista o se provare quella fruttariana
Ha vinto la crudista, grazie.
Vado a fare la spesa, che sarà per la
maggior parte frutta, carrube, non so
nemmeno cosa sia una carruba e vabbè ho
visto che praticamente non si può mangiare
un c***o. Chiedo scusa alle persone che magari
mi diranno "Se volevi dimagrire bastava che
mangiavi poco e che facessi una dieta
equilibrata".
Io equilibrio? Dove? Vabbè iniziamo. Tiè cioè ho speso
qualcosa tipo 50 euro.
Ma che è quella roba lì? E' pizza vostra?
Perché in tutto questo loro se so fatti la
pizza mentre io sono entrato con
le angurie. Sto mangiando mandorle da...
un quarto d'ora e ho beccato quell'unica
mandorla che rovina poi il sapore di tutte
le altre mandorle e la banana ho magnato
Stasera sushi. Si vola, si vola! Oh si
Sono tornato a casa e mentre Rosario qua...
Rosario pulisce l'angolo, io muoio di
fame e credo che andrò a farmi
un'ennesima banana, che per carità è un frutto
nobilissimo se non fosse la ventesima
che magno, no scherzo la seconda. Cioè io
oggi sto andando avanti a na banana e
mandorle, così, perché mi odio... Sto
mangiando finocchi
Stamattina mi sono svegliato
relativamente tardi e dopo il sushi di
ieri non avevo tanta fame. Credo che
questo senso di sazietà veramente non
sia dovuto al fatto che questa dieta io
lo stia facendo in maniera corretta
piuttosto è dovuto dal fatto che ho
mangiato così tanto, che secondo me
veramente io ancora ho in circolo roba di
capodanno, quindi la mia vera
preoccupazione è che oggi possa
incominciare a farsi sentire la fame ed
è il motivo per cui io, visto che
comunque io ho, sono un Precog, riesco a
capire il futuro in parte,
ho deciso di farmi per pranzo una
ricetta buonissima. Avete presente quelle
cose che su internet dicono "Delizioso
queste mandorle stato proprio di formaggio"
Ecco, farò quella e vedremo come va,
perché se non mi ingozzo perbene arrivo
stasera che le mele piuttosto che magnarmele me le infilo, non so, a voi
l'immaginazione. Ciao, inutile, inutile,
no tu sei sempre stato inutile perché
manco t'accendi, però capito? Questo,
Oddio, Oddio santo scusatemi ragazzi per
questo spettacolo. Ho appena notato una
cosa, che questa ricetta qua vedete? Cos'è che dice
taglio... non riesco a leggere al contrario,
tagliolini di zucca, vabbè tagliolini di
zucca, io l'ho letta male e al posto della
zucca ho preso le zucchine
La cosa positiva è che ho preso pure
questa cosa su Amazon per cercare di
fare gli spaghetti dalle zucchine, che
per me è un pochino come fare, non lo so
le bistecche dagli infissi, non so come si faccia
Ok ragazzi, ci sto riuscendo un po' a
fatica. Oddio porno Youtube, porno Youtube
Guardate che carini (*verso catarroso*), poco catarro.
Tadà, allora l'aspetto non è orribile nel senso
ho mangiano cose più brutte di questa roba.
E il terrore è il sapore, ma che
assaggeremo adesso. Le bacchette perché
fanno più food blogger. Bel mappazzone
Ragazzi...non fa c****e-
La mia domanda è, ci arrivo vivo, tipo
allo spuntino? E' buonissimo... buono. Inizio a crepare di fame
Sono uscito, grazie a Dio mi sono portato
una banana e ormai sto diventando un
primate, perché mi sto mangiando solamente
banane, non so quanto potassio possa
reggere un corpo prima che si trasformi
in veleno, se qualcuno lo sa me lo faccia
sapere qua sotto, e sono tornato a casa.
Non mi va minimamente di cucinare e quindi
ho ordinato di nuovo il sushi e di nuovo
mangerò sashimi. Anche se sto facendo un pochino
di ironia su Instagram, la cosa che ho
notato è che ho più energie
non so se è quel piccolo boost di energia
che si dice alcune persone abbiano prima
di apprestarsi alla morte, anche perché
ieri a cena ho beccato dei ragazzi
simpaticissimi e secondo me ho fatto
una pessima impressione
Aspettiamo il cibo, che si sbrigassero
*Luigi che parla*
No non posso mangiare l'integrale, Lu non posso
mangiare l'integrale, posso solamente
mangiare crudo, perché l'integrale è comunque
cotto, capisci la follia?
Non capisco come mangino i carboidrati
loro. Terzo giorno, continua pranzo a base
di sushi ma hanno spiegato che avrò
delle reazioni allergiche e che non è una
cosa sana e desidero questo riso più di
quanto possa desiderare ...mi vengono solo
battute sconce, quindi la chiudo qua.
Che buona, una cena offerta qui dalla mia
amica. Non mi stai inqudrando... No infatti ti metto ti metto una censura
perché sarebbe veramente un atto cattivo.
Grazie. Calcola in questo momento sei come quelli
intervistati dalle Iene, che avranno la
voce modificata e una censura sulla
faccia, quindi puoi dire quello che ti pare. Anche brutto s****o?
Va benissimo, però te lo posso dire io "brutta s*****a, eh? Che bello. Allora questa qui è un insalata di
mandarini, di cui alcuni sono cosparsi di
liquame, vogliamo far vedere? Ma comunque
mi sembrano M&M's. Una mela che stava
lì da quanto, perché voi non ve la siete
mangiata. Nono quella da poco. E poi rucola e... valeriana... che non lo so, per uno
che sta morendo di fame sono un pacco di
patatine. Aggiungiamo sesamo, sti
lamponi. Ma me sto a fa un'insalata o un
dolce? Perché non l'ho capito. Ma vanno bene
tutti questi lamponi? No ce ne sono un paio mosci. No te prego non è una crostata, dai basta. In tutto questo io
mangio davanti a questo, possiamo aprire un
attimo scusami, il frigo?... Cioè ragazzi io
devo resistere a tutta sta roba qui, io
solitamente qui apro ed è la cuccagna e
invece oggi se piagne....Oddio, sta luce così.
Questa dieta sta iniziando a
risultare pesante, mangio almeno, sempre
le stesse cose, in realtà mangio cose
diverse ma mi sembra sempre di mangiare
la stessa roba freschina, cruda, che
ti si piazza sullo stomaco e là rimane e
quindi incomincia a diventare un po'
stressante. Ieri sera poi è successa una
cosa che non ho ripreso, per rispetto
delle altre persone, perché dopo la cena
che ho fatto a casa dei miei amici sono
uscito a cena fuori con altre persone e mi sembrava brutto riprendere tutti quanti e ho
preso un' insalata, n'altra, cioè capito è tutto
tipo di insalata, mentre loro si sono
sfondati ragazzi, pizze, bruschette,
fritti, cose che io lunedì prossimo ci
vado. Viene anche da chiedermi che senso abbia fare
sta dieta se poi mi lancio lunedì a
mangiare pizza non stop, però sono stato bravo
non ho toccato nulla. Inizia a diventare
pesante e oggi salgo a Milano
vado da Lu. Io non posso manco mangià sashimi ogni sera, cioè si posso. Voi avete la
torta della nonna in frigo e i
bocconcini di pollo all'arancia
Che nessuno mangia, eccetto i bocconcini di
pollo. Perché?
Sto a dieta, vedi? Perché hai magnato du carote?
guarda che mica le carote so tipo le pillole
dimagranti. Fanno bene
alla vista... e ar c***o...Mangerò questa insalata di
funghi crudi con limone e compagnia
bella,
e sto bacile de finocchi, non ce la
faccio più sto mangiando solo finocchi,
mi sembra di stare al pride
La cosa veramente scomoda di questa
dieta, è che se sei di fretta come lo sono io
adesso, devo fare 2000 appuntamenti e
compagnia bella
E' difficile fare una colazione al volo,
Che ti magni a colazione?  Latte e cereali
latte e biscotti. Eh ma so cotti,
attraversano tutti quanti comunque dei
processi. Latte. Ma il latte per poter
essere parzialmente scremato o intero
viene prima fatto bollire perché bisogna
prendere, capito? Vabbè!
E te l'ho detto, che di per se non è malvagio, ma è un
po' difficile, cioè devi conoscere una dieta
così! Devi informarti cosa che... e scusami...
non ho fatto... E il salmone crudo? Viene
cotto in congelatore... No viene abbattuto in
congelatore non viene cotto. Mmm ne sei sicuro? Ma che cosa stai dicendo?
La cottura non avviene solo tramite
fuoco. Eh, ma tramite? Freddo. Anche..i cibi si cuociono
Vabbè io continuo co sta roba
vediamo, più che altro cioè sto per
andare a Milano. Guarda in questo momento ci sono io
con la Madonna dietro e la dice lunga su
come mi sento in questo momento
Mmm non lo so, non lo so, sono molto...cosa?
Che i cibi nel congelatore si cuociono, e sei rimasto
Senti tanto deve durare altri tre giorni...
ridi su sto c***o
E' bollente a dir poco. Ecco la dieta. Questi guarda che non so grassi
Mamma cosa c'è là dentro? Pollo e arance
basta? Si, vengono con la farina eh, soffritti in farina. Ah, soffritti in farina
Ci piaciu la farina eh? Ci piaci u cabboidrato
Se chiudo gli occhi e butto indietro
la lingua, sanno di pollo all'arancia
Guldo! Vuoi qualcosa di crudista? Vieni qua, no no no non volevo dirtelo, no poverino, no no ti ho preso
in giro scusami, odio prendere in giro le
persone innocenti. Aggiornamenti del
crudismo, sono qui arrivato a Milano
con Lu che sta male, saluta. Morto
Questo è il mio crudismo. Il tuo crudismo è, sono le sue medicine
poverino. Ho mangiato un po' di
mele mentre stavo in treno ma, sento che
mi fa uno, male la pancia e due, che io non mi
sento sazio
no io me sento pieno, pieno de plastica,
tipo pieno di roba che non riesco a
buttare giù e a digerire. Mi sta un pò
antipatica sta dieta devo essere sinc...
cioè magari non la so fare io. Altri due giorni al massimo  e via
Ma poi stasera che faccio, io ho
voglia di nuovo di mangiare qualcosa di
reale, ma è la dieta del sashimi, questa non è la dieta del crudismo. Come fate, che ricette
conoscete che io non sto capendo? E' un limite mio, non mi sono forse documentato, avrei dovuto
avere un professionista che mi seguisse.
Troppo salmone crudo secondo me, troppo
non so quanto vada bene, quel mercurio
con tutte quelle malattie lì, guarda che
tra tonno e salmone sono i pesci
peggiori. Te lo dico per esperienza nel senso che
no sul serio con le mie diete della palestra
io ho mangiato delle quantità industriali di tonno e... poi?... e a un certo punto so stato male... Ah io mo per
quattro giorni me sto male? E vabbè è andata così
mozzarella, croccante di suino, vabbè chissenefrega, vado? Si.... Patate crude con
provola, guanciale di suino nero è
così?
è tutto, è tutto crudo. Speravo di essere più forte. Delle
patatine con scamorza e bacon crudiste
So che sembra un hamburger cotto,
con bacon, scamorza, e tipo, non lo so pure
le mutande di mia nonna, me in realtà è
crudista, ve lo giuro ve lo giuro. Anche
quello è crudista. Buongiorno è sempre
giorno anche se a casa di Lu le luci da
vecchi la fanno sempre sembrare che tu ti
sei svegliato alle tre di notte per
andare a pisciare. Sto molto meglio con
la pancia, dopo
diciamo questo break. Anch'io sto molto meglio. Stai molto meglio, son contento Lu
diciamo m'ha dato la forza per ritornare
in carreggiata quindi adesso sto facendo
un pranzo a base di toast crudisti.
Guardate quanto è incredibile
il wrustel crudista. Lì che cos'è che abbiamo
invece? Qua abbiamo sul serio dell'avocado
pomodoro, crudi. Guarda il formaggio come
sembra
cioè il formaggio crudista sembra formaggio filante. Si sembra quasi cotto
E' vero è pazzesco abbiamo trovato questo posto,
guarda! L'uovo finto, pazzesco! Procede la
cena, qui abbiamo però tutta quanta roba
crudista perché comunque abbiamo aglio,
prezzemolo, pomodoro, vabbè
del sale e non ho mai mangiato quella
roba al tartufo e poi loro, delle vongole
crudiste, cioè che per il momento stanno
lì, non sono cotte e non si stanno manco
aprendo, quindi adesso dovrò utilizzare
altri ...Noo, nessuna di voi si muove?
Signor limone, tu che stai lì a guardia. Niente? Bene. Allora ok per questa pasta alle vongole crudista
bisogna ad un certo punto mettere gli spaghetti
a macerare in acqua frizzante, invece
vedete che fa tutte le bollicine
l'acqua e poi invece a parte mettete a
macerare le vongole con il pomodoro
nell'olio e aglio e teoricamente dovrebbe
venirvi vedete fuori, una una crema così
le vongole rilasceranno questo liquido e
dovrebbe insomma, venire una roba
crudista. Cosa? Le fiamme. Ah si, no quelli sono dei led
sono dei led che ho messo apposta. E l'uva spremuta a mano...bravissimo... raccolta in un
in una bottiglia, potete anche usare quelle del vino se, se volete. Quelle col sottomano. Esatto, se ce l'avete
Tu che bravo che sei stato a
metterci il tappo di nuovo, che bravo
E questo è il risultato della, diciamo
degli spaghetti con le vongole crudisti
Come va? Buonissimi! Un po' salati eh?Un tantino...ho
cercato di portare il... hai marinato troppo
esatto, esatto il sale. Diciamo che volevo
portare il mare a tavola. Ci sei riuscito. Allora ragazzi
qualora non si sia capito la dieta
crudista è il male
per quanto mi riguarda, sono sicuro di
aver sbagliato 200.000 cose ma allo
stesso tempo credo e magari chi è
crudista melo potrà scrivere qui e potrà
dirmi e potrà contraddirmi, ma credo che
per il mio stomaco, dopo un po' mangiare
crudo sia veramente un inferno, vi dico
solo c'avevo una panza piena d'aria
ma che sembravo incinta e l'unico
modo che avevo per togliere quella panza
era partorire tutta quell'aria e non era
bello per me e per chi mi stava attorno
Detto ciò vi saluto, credo di avere, di
aver condiviso con voi un pò troppe
informazioni, ma vabbè, vi mando un bacio, al
prossimo video, ciao ragazzi
Mamma mia era più buona sta videocamera che
quello che ho magnato fino ad oggi